y abiertamente la junta militar ya
confirmó la muerte de este centenar de
personas y entre los que como le
mencionaba hay varios menores de edad y
justifica esta acción militar Más allá
de las condenas internacionales de los
organismos que repercusiones puede traer
Esto entonces para la junta militar
Hola Santiago bueno Esto no es una
novedad quiero decir es una tragedia una
salvajada 100 muertos en lo que se
considera va a ser difícil identificarlo
será más de 120 todavía se sigue se
sigue buscando gente después de los
bombardeos apareció el helicópteros
también disparando la multitud hace
pocos meses también en un concierto de
música al aire libre también atacaron
los militares que han tomado el tema de
los bombardeos como una práctica
sistemática de ataque a las aldeas donde
hay grupos étnicos que no son obedientes
a este gobierno que es un gobierno
militar surgido de un golpe de estado
Lamentablemente creo que las
repercusiones a pesar de la gravedad del
hecho van a ser solo declaraciones y
nada más
señor Pedraza el gobierno de myanmar es
decir esta junta militar ha dado
información escueta sobre lo que ellos
califican como terroristas estamos
hablando de un acto en una comunidad por
parte de integrantes de partidos
opositores quienes pueden ser entonces
una amenaza terrorista al interior del
país o esto se trata entonces de un acto
deliberado digamos
Este es un gobierno ilegítimo es un
gobierno producto de un golpe militar
el grupo bombardeado no está considerado
como terrorista por
ninguna agencia internacional ni ni por
los demás países del mundo sino que son
los miembros del gobierno de puesto Yo
quiero decir algo muy sencillo acá el
culpable de esto el responsable máximo
esto es el gobierno militar de mi ámbar
pero también son los gobiernos que le
venden armas como en este caso Rusia los
gobiernos que lo protegen en la
comunidad internacional como China y
además quiero decir también puntualmente
que la comunidad internacional tiene una
gran responsabilidad
alguna prensa norteamericana New York
Times de Washington post se han dedicado
a castigar al gobierno democrático
anterior al de ausensuchi hasta de
legitimarlo y ahora nadie dice más nada
no estamos frente a una mujer presa en
pésimas condiciones hace dos años más de
dos años y el movimiento feminista
tampoco dice nada mi amar Es un país
cuidado por la comunidad occidental no y
creo que hay que llamar la atención para
que estas bestialidades no solo se
repitan sino que van creciendo además en
ese orden de ideas señor Pedraza
Entonces los militares se aferran al
poder cambian las leyes para perpetuarse
reciben apoyo de algunos países
internacionales y los organismos
internacionales tampoco hacen nada
Entonces qué garantías hay para los
ciudadanos en materia de Derechos
Humanos de garantizarles las leyes y sus
derechos y de garantizarles derechos
básicos Como por ejemplo un derecho
democrático como votar o elegir
la ciudadanía mía no tiene ningún
derecho está sometida a un régimen
militar que está que ya está destruyendo
más la economía la poca educación la
poca salud la poca infraestructura que
tiene este país el crecimiento de las
enfermedades de crimen organizado del
narco la situación de Miramar es
dramática y también son responsables de
esto los países vecinos agrupados en
asean que están siendo testigos de los
exilios de los movimientos de población
que se van desesperados de Miramar y de
la guerra civil que está sometiendo al
país a más de tres mil muertos en los
últimos dos años y más de 20 mil presos
políticos